pouvant le train qui est tranquille à la
basse comme ça qu'il est toujours dans
le show business c'est bien mais fais
attention méfie toi il faut pas péter
plus haut que son derrière
sinon tu vas plus de la gueule ah oui et
puis il faut jamais insulter un
crocodile avant de traverser la rivière
mais tant qu'il n'y a pas de crocodile
aux antilles non mais y'a des rivières
on est bien là tranquille tranquille
excuse moi parce que tout soit deux
secondes que je fasse mes cases que ta
volonté soit faite
merci jésus le sauveur j'ai perdu deux
kilos
on est bien là tranquille bon pascal tu
vas t'y poche un petit web n'ont pas de
rome site rotonde encore en tout cas
pascal si l'on voit ou te gêne dans ton
travail supprime le travail